- [Narrator] With a lifespan
able to reach as old as 69,
these iguanas can live as long as humans.
This is the Grand Cayman blue iguana.
(light music)
Found only in Grand Cayman,
the largest and western most
of the Cayman Islands,
their blue skin becomes more
prominent when establishing territory
when other iguanas are nearby.
Males turn especially bright
blue during breeding season,
but their blue skin isn't
their only defining feature.
They have striking red
eyes and excellent vision,
which enables them to
notice shapes and movement
at long distances.
Listed as endangered
due to human activity,
habitat loss, and being preyed upon by
free-roaming predators such as dogs,
cats, and rats, these
beautiful blue lizards
face an uphill battle against extinction.
This is the Grand Cayman blue iguana.
(light music)